did you know that this was coming like
did you wear that t-shirt on purpose no
no I was actually sleeping in it that's
the irony CNN was told about my arrest
prior to my lawyers being told of my
arrest well they said it was just a
reporter's intuition which is why he was
there and it happened do you believe
that buddy but if I am dangerous why
would they be allowed to be 25 feet from
the strip from the front door the rest
of the street was sealed and cleared of
everybody I think that's gonna I'm glad
to see Senator Lindsey Graham looking
into that because I think that will be
disproved that they were just operating
on a hunch I look I I don't own a
firearm I don't have a valid passport
I'm not a flight risk I'm charged with
nonviolent processed crimes
I have no previous criminal record I'm
in my mid-60s all in pretty damn good
shape and they know that I'm represented
they could have contacted my lawyer and
I would have turned myself in so this
was a you know it's a purposeful show of
force they rousted my my wife they
marched her out in the street a
nightgown and bare feet
she's hearing-impaired
I was concerned that they would think
she wasn't complying with an instruction
and shooter one more gemandsam catch up
with full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM